okay here we go
[Music]
friends they're always there for us even
though the show went off the air over 15
years ago we can still count on Monica
Chandler Ross Rachel Joey and Phoebe to
bring the funny sometimes though they
seemed to lose the plot yes as
entertaining as friends could be over
ten seasons the show managed to rack up
quite a few plot holes in this video
we're taking a look at some of the most
noteworthy just don't order a garden
salad and then eat my food friends makes
a point of emphasizing Joey Ross and
Chandler's love of die hard starring
Bruce Willis over the years they
apparently have gotten together to watch
it repeatedly yet in season six when
Ross is dating Elizabeth Stephens and
meets her father Paul no one seems to
notice he looked some familiar Paul is
played by none other than Bruce Willis
the star of the guys favorite movie yet
somehow no one makes the connection
there's not even a joke about Paul
looking eerily similar to Willis to
acknowledge the absurdity of course this
is the paradox of fiction where an actor
can both exist in the universe of and
play a character in a TV show you know
why because you're a neat guy remember
the season one Thanksgiving episode the
one where underdog gets away it's the
one where the underdog balloon gets away
during the Thanksgiving Day Parade in
New York City the friends even run to
the roof to marvel at the rare sight but
Monica apparently already experienced
this unusual occurrence for episodes
earlier when Monica goes on a double
date with Joey she talks about seeing an
underdog balloon getaway during a parade
was Monica predicting the future
or was the underdog balloon getting away
a lot more common than friends would
have us believe Joey was the friend who
had a way with the ladies throughout the
series
Joey dated so many women it's easy to
lose track of them all and most of them
never lasted more than an episode then
there was Rachel mani fans cringe at the
later season storyline where
and Joey get together but Joey confessed
it was a landmark for him because he was
in love with her I think I'm falling in
love with you her and it was the first
time he'd felt that way if we look back
in friends as lore however this isn't
quite true at one point
Chandler tells a story about Joey being
in love with a girl in the past even
more important though is Joey's
relationship with fellow actor Kate
Miller in season 3 Joey really gets to
know Kate and is genuinely falling for
her but Kate dumps him to pursue her
career leaving Joey devastated it seems
like Joey hasn't only had eyes for
Rachel because it's impossible to find
her apartment she lives in like some hot
girl parallel universe or something Oh
Ross you are so confusing
Ross confesses when he finally
consummated his relationship with his
first wife Carol he told everyone about
it he was stoked because it was his
first time in your whole life you only
know with one oh that means when the
pair broke up at the beginning of the
series Ross had only been with one woman
but throughout the show we discover
that's not true in season seven Ross
admits he slept with his and Chandler's
cleaning lady in college Chandler got
drunk and slept with a lady who cleaned
our dorm that was you if he was so proud
of sleeping with Carol why was he so
reluctant to admit his exploits with the
cleaning lady and why would he lie about
how many women he's been with Oh Ross
you kissed a guy before he got together
with Monica Chandler dated Janice on and
off despite finding her incredibly
irritating he never seemed to be able to
shake her for good so when he got back
together with her in season 4 rather
than dumping her he developed an
elaborate ruse to escape the
relationship he told her you know I'm
packing because I'm moving to Yemen
tomorrow making it impossible for them
to be together but Janice wanted to milk
every last bit of time they had together
before Chandler left so she packed with
him and waited until his flight bored
and at the airport this forced Chandler
to get on the plane and it seemed like
he must have gone to Yemen yet somehow
Chandler was back in New York the very
next episode and the whole Yemen
incident was never mentioned to get can
I stay with you
Joey is known as the dim bulb of the
friends this is often played for laughs
but sometimes it seems like the show's
writers made poor Joey even stupider
than he deserves
for example in season six Joey says I'm
using air quotes correctly while saying
the word star then in season 9 when Ross
uses air quotes
Joey stops him because he when people do
this I don't really know what that means
Joey then proceeds to use them
incorrectly multiple times later in the
episode Joey is also inconsistent in his
understanding of Adam's apples in an
early episode he mentions that the first
woman he hooked up with in the city had
a giant Adam's apple ignoring the fact
that women don't have Adam's apples
later he refers to it as his Joey's
Apple it hurts my Joey's Apple
apparently this is because he believes
this piece of anatomy is named after
each individual man it's funny sure but
how is Joey forgetting so many things
fans have pointed out many times that
all the friends apartments seem
ridiculous given they live in uber
expensive New York City but most
ridiculous of all maybe the fancy
one-bedroom in Greenwich Village that
Phoebe lives in at the beginning of the
series Phoebe works as a freelance
masseuse she even goes through periods
of unemployment and in season two she
along with Joey and Rachel talk about
not earning a lot of money so how can
she afford her posh place and manage to
live there by herself no less in the
season 1 episode the one where Nana dies
twice
Ross and Monica lose their maternal
grandmother yet their maternal
grandparents are brought up at least two
more times in a way that makes it seem
the writers forgot about this episode in
season 7 Monica and Ross's father jack
tells Chandler that he's lied to his
in-laws for years about being a lawyer
what did you do when they found out they
never did here he asks Chandler to just
agree with them if Chandler ever sees
him give his wife's parents legal advice
but this is obviously impossible since
Nana died years before then in season 10
Monica and Ross
mother claims her parents died young yet
clearly Nana was anything but young when
she passed away
my parents died very young and my
cholesterol is off the charts in
hindsight one of the less funny aspects
of friends was the flashbacks to Monica
as an overweight teen poor Monica
deserved better than to be mocked for
her weight still it was a
well-established fact of her existence
as was Ross's frequent visits home
during college accompanied by Chandler
yet when the friends watch the video of
Monica and Rachel's prom Chandler is
shocked at how big Monica was this
shouldn't have come as a surprise given
how often he was over at her place when
she was a teen though not to mention he
was the one who's cruel comments
inspired her to lose weight in the first
place no it's not that I just wanna be
stuck here all night with your fat
sister hey in the very first episode of
Friends
Monica introduces runaway bride Rachel
to the group including Chandler yet all
of them must have been suffering from
amnesia
since Chandler and Rachel met at least
four separate occasions in the episode
the one with all the Thanksgivings
Chandler attends the Gellers
Thanksgiving celebration during college
on two separate occasions and meets
Rachel both times and in the one with
the flashback the friends remember a
time when Chandler and Rachel crossed
paths at a bar then in season 10 another
flashback shows Rachel not only met but
made out with Chandler at a party the
night before her SATs if that didn't
make the pair remember one another who
knows what would 16 years ago Ross as we
already mentioned is confusing and that
extends to his feelings about delightful
frozen treats in season 7 Ross declares
he doesn't like ice cream because it's
too cold toward sleepy
he shares an ice cream cone with the
monkey Marcel and then when he's dating
Elizabeth in season six they're shown
eating ice cream too was Ross just
suffering through those desserts
in season eight Phoebe doesn't know what
the French word su means when Monica
introduces Phoebe to her sous chef
actually she's my boss who is French for
under
also in season seven
when Monica asks Phoebe for her
grandmother's cookie recipe Phoebe
claims it came from her grandmother's
grandmother Phoebe's great-great
grandmother's name a French accented
version of Nestle Tollhouse Phoebe mocks
Monica's Americanized pronunciation of
the brand my season ten no Phoebe is
fluent in French and trying to teach it
to Joey
how did she learned the language so fast
the episode the one where Chandler can't
cry is all about you guessed it
Chandler's inability to cry he claims he
hasn't shed a tear since he was a kid
but there's plenty of evidence to the
contrary
not only does Phoebe recount a story
about making Chandler cry in season 3
but when Ross decides to make both Joey
and Chandler the best man for his
wedding to Emily they all tear up so
apparently the show couldn't be more
wrong about Chandler that story doesn't
make you cry no I don't cry it's not a
big deal Chandler is even confused about
his fitness goals in the one in Vegas
which appropriately takes place in Vegas
Chandler says that you know if I want
$5,000 I'd join a gym you know build up
my upper body apparently that's the only
thing standing between Chandler and
getting fit yet earlier in the series
Ross tries to help Chandler quit his gym
and instead ends up joining himself a
whole episode is dedicated to the guy's
inability to quit the gym despite never
going there maybe it's been so long
since Chandler went to the gym that he
forgot he's a member you do realize you
won't have access to our new
full-service Swedish spa
the one thing that's clear from the
beginning of the show is that Joey has a
lot of sisters in fact he has so many
sisters he seems unclear just how many
there are in the season 1 episode Joey
says his mother you think it's easy
giving birth to seven children giving
Joey is also her child that would mean
Joey has six sisters but in season three
when the sisters appear there are seven
of them that would mean that mrs.
Tribbiani had eight children and when
Joey sets Phoebe up with future husband
Mike joy signals that he has Seven
Sisters maybe maybe maybe this is all a
product of Joey's poor math skills what
are you doing I said seven one of the
strangest reoccurring issues and friends
is the neverending confusion over the
six main characters ages this seems to
start with Ross Ross claims to be 29
years old and seasons 3 4 & 5 of the
show no thanks I'm 29 given each season
covers about a year in the friends lives
that's just not possible and get
divorced for the second time before I'm
30
Ross also claims that his birthday is in
December at one point and that another
says it's in October
Monica seems to have the same powers of
decelerated aging as her brother in
season 1 she claims to be 26 but she
doesn't turn 30 until season 7 and
rachel is similarly confused about her
birth month at first she says her
birthday's in May later when a cop pulls
her over though he observes she's an
Aquarius in Aquarius which would put her
birthday in January or February not only
are the friends individually confused
about their ages they're collectively
confused too at different points Rachel
and Joey are both said to be the
youngest in the group but there can only
be one and the group should know who it
is the birth of Ross's son Ben was a
major part of friends first season
[Music]
and been continued to show up
periodically after he was born
demonstrating he was still very much a
part of Ross's life that is until the
middle of season 8 when he disappeared
and was never seen again after Rachel
and Ross's daughter Emma was born it
seems Ross no longer considered Ben at
all
poor kid how could you forget about your
own son Ross speaking of things the
friends forget in season 1 a major
plotline hinged on Rachel and Monica
getting locked out of their apartment on
Thanksgiving this would make sense if
they ever seemed to lock their doors
earlier in the very same episode
Chandler barges in the apartment no key
required how is this possible if they
keep their doors locked
which of these friends plot holes will
you be paying attention to on your next
re watch have you spotted others that we
missed give us how you doin in the
comments and let us know and don't
forget to like this video and subscribe
for more awesome videos from the things
thanks for watching
[Music]